The Joe Rogan Experience but their
people have those things they have those
uh wolf breeds wolf dogs
there's one guy I knew had three of them
and you would go over his house if you
made noise
they would all just Howl in it's they're
not dogs it's so interesting they like
there's no like telling them what to do
sit lay down [__] you those songs should
be out in the wild yeah and this guy had
him in a yard it's like it's kind of
crazy that's not what they should be
these dogs are wild they should be um
you know it's also kind of crazy to fix
them
he's just cutting off their testosterone
supplies oh
let's get done I bet they're still
pretty aggressive they're not the same
they're definitely not the same I mean I
get it that you don't want them to have
puppies but you should just be in
control of your dog
it's such a weird animal
wolves
you know because we killed him off and
now we're like let's bring them back and
have them in the park with other dogs
that are have no Fighting Chance against
if it goes nuts well that case that guy
you know had it supposedly as a pet I
just think people get pets sometimes
it's like you don't have to really know
what you're doing to get or a German
Shepherd you can get a police dog German
Shepherd like a really aggressive very
smart thinking like almost like a
predator of people yeah you know and you
could just get it anybody can get it I
mean somebody I think in Manhattan had
like an alligator oh yeah like you get
these like little animals where they're
cute and then it like gets to be
humongous and you're like this is a real
problem I think a dude in the Bronx had
a tiger sure I see that happen in this
[__] house this guy had a tiger at
his house
yeah people are nuts imagine like
telling a girl at a club you have a baby
tiger like even if you don't want to
[__] this guy like I do want to see this
baby tiger
where was this
this is his alligator found in New York
City Lake oh my God
so what do you think happened there you
think that was like it's probably a pet
and it got you big and somebody was like
I don't know what to do with this and he
put it in this park in the water that's
the story of Florida
Florida is an amazing story
Florida is just overrun with Pythons
there's a half a million pythons in the
Everglades they said that 99 of all of
the mammals are gone
of everything raccoons deer everything
rabbits they're all gone
foxes Pumas everything everything maybe
that's what you need to be hunting then
yeah well they are doing that what's
crazy is in California python skins
illegal
you can't expand you can't get python in
California meanwhile on the other side
of the country they're overrun with
Pythons like they literally have wiped
out all the native Wildlife they're
eating alligators now that's crazy yeah
yeah
tiger living in Harlem apart oh my God
oh my God yeah that's the part of the
story I mean imagine showing up to that
and you're like I'm out of here oh my
God I'm not getting paid enough for this
I think they're the most beautiful
animals they're beautiful but like what
are you doing in a tiny studio apartment
with a tiger it's an insane person
it's like some dude who met some dude
who knows a guy of course do you know
there's more tigers in Texas in private
collections than there are in all of the
wild of the world
are they just like in their private
backyards and stuff tiger world I mean
when they attack people I'm like yeah I
get it why you you're caging this analog
to be in the wild yeah Texas is very
strange when it comes to Wildlife you
can kind of own anything
Texas this is
not here anything goes get you a zebra
Adrian I want a baby zebra not when it
gets big once it gets big I'm gonna put
in that lake with that alligator
I care fend for yourself
yeah there's that's apparently like a
couple thousand more tigers in Texas
than there are in the wild did you ever
watch Tiger King oh yeah I mean just
like such trash I was so great not so
secretly hoping that Trump would pardon
him
huh
that's like probably a third level
education well he's just trying to make
money talk to those straight guys into
[__] them so respect yeah but I feel
like rich people can get away with that
it's like why women right hot women [__]
ugly dudes that are rich you're like
well hopefully guys yes absolutely I
guess with some guys but everything it's
like what works on everybody you know
because like some things don't work on
some people they work on other people
I think money always works on everyone